when able T Luhan is not teaching
digital media at the American University
in Washington DC the 34 year old can be
found in his studio in addis ababa
converting his imagination into images
what inspires me the most is really
relationships relationships between
people and time relationships between
history and the current relationships
between us and nature our relationships
between our ancestors and also our
descendants Abel says every idea can be
best expressed through a particular
media and that's why he uses a
combination of installation video art
drawing and sound design it creates this
narrative of of the today meeting the
past and also the future as well so
using certain technological innovations
like video or the LED lights as you can
see behind me we can contrast it with
the with the past each of our bills
artworks takes between two months to two
years to create and the pieces all deal
with aspects of time or timelessness in
this work he documents injera an
Ethiopian food staple made from tough
grains lights in the shape of a circle
change in intensity around silicon
objects depicting how much some things
in life stay the same those who have
seen the work are impressed by the
concept it's fantastic incredible
because in general used by most
Egyptians and he'll and it's very much
connected with the culture and the also
his food and and bring food to the
visual kind of art is something special
actually and I admire and appreciate the
way he
he really picked this idea this piece is
called brain drain Abel arranges
sculptures on a spiral staircase to
depict a hierarchy of brains one side of
the brain we have this anatomically
correct brain sculpture the right
hemisphere is depicted as as a very like
you know that because the right
hemisphere deals with memory and and
innovation artistic expression and these
things it takes to become imaginary as
opposed to an ultimately correct Abel
says living in both the US and Ethiopia
helps him to access contrasting ideas
from different cultures and create
artworks that investigate the
relationship between time and space
[Music]